ma fille elle est pas partie pour faire
la guerre ma fille elle est partie pour
danser elle est elle est jeune elle est
pas vu elle a pas vu rien dans sa vie
déjà rien on veut savoir si elle est
vivante mort on lâchera pas
l'affaire on demande que Céline mère de
Ellie
revienne
Shalom le
couam moi je suis Doron je suis le père
de car moi je suis Doron je suis le père
de Karine Karine est
elle est partie voà pour pour danser
après un peu avec les les copines
et m'a invité message
à samedi à
8h4 il m' envé tes messages dans un
portable
que elle a marqué pour toute la famille
je vais te dire que je vous t'aime je je
t'aime beaucoup parce que je je retourne
pas à la maison depuis cette message on
n pas entendu rien on sait pas si elle
est
mort si elle est à
Gaza on sait pas rien du tout samedi
matin Céline avec deux amis est parti à
ce festival et dans la route à
6h30 comme tout le monde en Israël il y
avait les roquettes les alarmes et ils
ont décidé de faire demi-tour pour
rentrer et ils ont arrivé à un
abri dans la route et euh et là de tous
l'information que eux ils ont collecté
ont et là ils ont rencontré les
terroristes de Hamas et probablement
cine était kidnappée vers Gaza on n rien
attendu depuis samedi matin à 7h15 de
Céline nous avons une bébé une petite
bébée que probablement vous avez tous vu
etit dans les média elle est devenue
elle s'app s'appelle maintenant le bébé
de la France je vous en prie ramenez ma
femme ramener C